[Music]
so
okay the uh
first thing to understand is the
starting my first strike
okay
um it is much closer
than you want to think okay
so if i
imagine like last night's drill
right
it was working on the counter right
okay
um
so
if i had the mentality it was a strike
that's a strike counter right as a
strike and it was off the lead jab
counter the lead jab with a counter
right okay
if i had the aikido mentality the one
that you have now for striking
and i'm being you get so he has his
garga i would have been doing that stuff
for mike
but no one did that because that's
clearly intuitively wrong okay
um
there's no need for a counter
if he's gonna start his strike from up
there so he's gonna do he's gonna start
his leech out from out there
you see okay so he's gonna hit me with
it
if he's gonna start his strike from out
there
don't engage the strike deviate deviate
okay it's very so he's going to start
his shominuchi from out there
you don't have to do anything
if you look at katata jody
and consider this wrist
the target
manucci's target
is further in do you see that
so if he attacks this target
from there
let's look at where he started
do you see
what do you want to say i don't know two
feet three feet
and now he's supposed to target this
target
cap got it
so
the distance from this target to this
target is probably another foot
at least
maybe more
so he should start if that's where he
starts to talk to he should be in that
one to maybe more feet in to hit this
target do you understand okay now
there's no time to get out of the way
there's no time to deviate like i was i
have to address that strength okay
so that strike starts here this is where
striking happens
uh he's not uh south paw but pretend you
already take cisgarda
we're back in striking range okay
so first understand the logic of where
the strike starts it does not start back
out here okay
dude this starts back out here i would
deviate or i'd have time to draw my
weapon in dpa okay so that's not where
this is started we're in tight okay
and then in keyhole he's going to strike
we say strike the back leg
okay that means he's going to just draw
a line across so he's going to step
through
and
he's not going to strike the front leg
okay and kihon you can change it and do
it that way but in our chemo he attacks
the back leg and he does it with a step
through you could of course have this be
his front hand and he goes with the
shuffle you could do it it doesn't
matter okay but we standardize and get
our keyboard
he comes in
and he steps in the eye on me
okay
all right
the first skill you want i was well
set it up so you learn the skill okay
um you're not going to strike him and
then he blocks that skill
other hand
because that's not a skill at all
there's also a weird understanding of
king han you describe his reaction
okay so we don't do that
second thing we don't do he strikes me
and i block
not it and then i go into
our manipulation you're not doing that
what's a block
he's coming up and i'm going up
he's coming up i'm going up that's a
block and i'm trying to stop him
you have to stop those two things
so it can't be me attacked he blocks
and it can't be he boom and i block
nor can it be that he just sticks his
hand out he won't know what to do yeah
it's just like you're dusting dust off
my head you see it can't be that either
because there was no downwardness to the
strike okay
and when you're trading shogunuchi
you're working on the energy on the
vertical plane so his strike has to come
up and his strike has to come down it's
not the sagittal plane it's not jodon's
ski okay with someone else's jordan
got it okay so once you're in that
environment
the skill the first one is the body
reading just like when we're here change
your stance how you like okay and he
goes i i can see the jab before it
manifests itself do you know that body
reading is a skill you need the skill
you can't fight without
reading the body okay
so
the first skill that i want
is
know where he's going
look for weight shifting look for
shoulder changing angles look for
inhalations look for nostrils flaring
eyes opening you have to have that
because you can't wait till you see the
strike you're gonna break the first one
of the first two rules probably number
two you're going to block it okay
so
first skill as he goes you read the body
so you know
and then the second skill is you match
yin and yang so the only opening for
showman in this case is when it's going
up that's the yin energy that's when i
can edie me without breaking rule number
two
so it goes up
and i catch it going up
i won't even talk about what i'm doing
there you just want it up
up
you're not waiting
front foot up
backward
we won't deal with the injury
okay let's try it go
okay so the last point is what to not do
though like uh not having to be a strike
blocking stopping those are all wrong
that's not aikido flat out got it so you
want to learn aikido don't do those
things
and then it creates the possibility for
this other yin yang reconciliation
there's only one yin spot on shomonucci
in this case and it's when he goes up so
i have to read the body so i can take
advantage of the opening when it goes up
okay
um
that's what's last point okay this point
what am i doing
um
my hands are going to be
uh as if you're in jordan
so you have your jodante savaki that you
would do
all the time
what that is is opening triangles
dominating the center line so you're
going to do the same thing now you don't
switch your hands apart it's not time to
split your hands yet it's the same thing
if we're if we're up close
and i feel him rising up to hit my head
i'm not going to open this up because
you're going to get hit but boom do you
got it so until he does something i will
guard the center line cover up my vital
areas on the top part of my body that's
going to be until i get my deviation do
you understand so don't open yourself up
keep yourself close so arm positioning
is here
with the other hand
in the hand sword position at the tricep
tendon of insertion
and the other hand is above that so the
two hands are working in conjunction
okay
if you're here
in the echo grab at the beginning
the other hand is below the elbow
that's not good because i'm on the
outside of the arm for example
if i do it over here let's just look at
this common mistake okay
i'm doing my control at the wrist
while you're doing that okay
how did you get there there's only one
way
i can't reach the wrist if i was
entering on the inn do you see there's
no way
so what do you think you did
you clashed
do you think
and in that class you also break the
rule right now on the outside of the arm
you need to be above the elbow in order
to generate the angle cancellation if
you're above that if you're below the
elbow then he can bend around it okay
so same thing if he's on the outside and
he only holds the wrist like a check and
it's easy to get around it same thing
he's at the wrist you're boom it's easy
to get around it happens instantly
and it hits okay
so whenever you're on the outside you
have to be at the elbow and i can't get
this joint to go around it it can't heal
without creating further opening
so
don't be on the wrist
it's not going to be right because you
only got there by clashing and then you
get no true angle cancellation
so he goes up
here
don't use this hand yet it's not
dominant it's just staying there
once i enter
what is next dominant
is the emote hip
so i push
[Music]
and create
the body lock here
my body is
doing it
so
up to my body
well you want your cushy involved you
get the body lock
[Music]
several points have to be vague at this
point
in order to get the body lock
i have to allow his lower half of his
body to continue going forward
you cannot
stop and push him he will never come on
to you okay
so this makes the technique consistent
with all the rest of your art
keep his forward energy going
don't stop his energy don't try to stop
and don't fight him okay
so
up
keep it going
how do you keep it going forward
don't push this back
up
and it's going to go around you
and then you're going to yield
it goes up
and around you
as you go inside it with your step
so
up
let it go around you
up let it go around you
so all you have to do is here
is establish the ground path
add the adhesion
and let go of it
and it will go around you and you have
to time your hip there
do not do this
do not push him backwards
oh boom watch how his hands well
if i stay here it'll run into me but i'm
not going to stay here
i go inside
inside
so you should read my body too right
which side is forward
soft you don't need to look at my feet
you look at my shoulders
he goes whoa inside
we're going to do you see
inside
no
hands in place inside
okay
don't stop him let his lower half keep
going forward
and let his arm go forward
once you get your admin entry angle okay
and then step your side inside what is
going to be the inertial resistance
you're using it okay go
okay so
what you're doing now
is increasing your partial viability
okay
it is more marginally viable to control
his
center of gravity his balance his
posture spine
than to control his arms
okay so that's what you're doing you're
not attacking his arm i am touching his
arm but i'm not attacking his arm i'm
getting his balance and getting his
center okay you have to understand that
you have to not go
and try some arm techniques
okay
so he's much stronger than me and
um
you see you go oh
i get it
full grown lever
okay so he's got fulcrum and lever got
it and he's gonna
get me down go ahead
go ahead
and even this little strength difference
uh he can't do it
no one can do it all you're going to do
is try it for real and you're going to
say that that didn't work okay and
you don't have to say
that the little 80 pound
drunk girl in heels that you're trying
to arrest for public intoxication was on
pcp it just doesn't work okay
the other thing is this
every fulcrum and lever
has its ideal positioning in order to
maximize its force output
that requires the fight to stop moving
that breaks the rules of fighting fights
don't stop moving okay
so if i stay still go ahead
and it's still not you try your hardest
it's still not enough to overcome me
even though you can
kill me on the bench press okay
but once i start moving i'm going to
change this idea i'll go ahead and admit
and it requires even less output on my
part to overcome that engine do you
understand okay so
therefore
do not try fulcrum lever on the arm it
does not work okay and it's not better
than what we're doing
so
don't
try to hit that wrist
and try to do that do you see that
in any of your sneaky ways
here
no
don't do it
attack the center attack the sensor in
here attack the center
that's your goal
if you have to think i'm not doing ikyo
then think you're not doing eco and just
do a new technique okay
so center there's your adhesion right
your eye adhesion you see i'm not i
don't need to do that because i don't
need to do that i'm using his energy
his inertia was going forward it's
pushing into this hand there's no need
to grab it
there's no need it just guide it around
what am i doing here if i'm not grabbing
it i'm staying with it
i'm not pushing it down don't push it
down don't pull it just stay with it
stay with it stay with it as it lowers
i'm staying with it
no
just get his center
center
no push pull
try to chill on your grabbing
and get your adhesion going instead
attack the center
use his inertial progress
to create the adhesion attack the sun
okay
it's going back a little bit i mentioned
it that you're using an eye candheation
to get that energy to come around you
and that's what's sticking his arm to
your
hands
you don't need to grab it okay
definitely why you don't want to do an
inferior method of fulcrum lever okay
so
in order to do an id adhesion his energy
has to go into the ground you see so
he's he's pushing you can push he's
pushing backwards right and that
energy's in the ground
as i'm moving
it's not me bracing on it not me bracing
on it okay this energy is
in the ground and that's as it turns
right that's what's allowing it
to go around
so you can't you can't do lurch stepping
you see that it can't be that so you're
going to go
from one mid foot vector
on the rear foot
to the other
you see
and you stay on that
midfoot vector
so you can't merge
boom
it's
all the time mid foot mid foot
no different than this drill i'm here
and i want to walk
mid foot
is bracing on me same exact thing
mid foot head foot left foot
you can't just walk
boom
in
the technique is a threat constantly to
the center
remember not arm to control center
center to control arm okay
so that means attack the center
attachment and attack the center
do not come off the center
this will answer the question well how
does the arm stay in place
how does it stick to me inertially at
the beginning
because it was going that way and here
because i'm going
into the arm got it i'm going into the
center the arm will stay in place
so you're going to go boom
i'm going to go
into the arm this is the arm
you're going to look for
the center
you're going to look for this attackable
angle
pull
down this angle
do not think table and legs do not think
table and legs
so don't go on
pull off his balance
pull him off his balance i'm not pulling
him off his bounce i'm taking the whole
table and i'm just flipping the whole
table over okay
so
in
think of this outer knee
being on the line of attack
of his face
if you need a reference point
right in line of attack
don't start fading out and go to the
extremities of the body
pop right there straight in
different
you're gonna have to catch that arm
i'm gonna change it
here i stayed with the arm okay
and now how do i get him down not by
pulling out
by
taking this angle here and that's where
i let it fall
in
here's where you let it fall
[Music]
as you can see i don't go down to the
wrist and key on okay
i'm not trying to hurt him i'm just
learning how to control the center now
for ballistic strikes instead of fixated
movement of the crabs
a lot of the difficulty comes from
what you're perceiving you're doing
if you perceive
that it's control the arm to control the
body then what i'm saying makes no sense
to you okay but
if you have experience
like
actually
trying to arrest someone who doesn't
want to get arrested
someone who's going to fight you back
you realize
this can't be it
okay and then opens the door for the
possibilities
i there is a place where i neither push
nor pull
okay
so for example
where
i don't need to
grab the arms to keep the arms
do you see the only reason i'm i need to
grab to keep the arms is i'm behind i'm
behind in my mind if i were to stay up i
don't need to grab the arms to keep the
arms do you see that but you have to
open yourself up to that possibility
okay
and you change things you ask the
question how do i keep up with the arms
such that i'm not behind such that i do
not have to pull the arms to keep the
arms you got it
so i gave you that angle of entry which
makes more sense okay
meaning
if this goes south
i get a knee kick or a mount
rather than start fighting on some guy's
arm that doesn't make sense that's not
marginally viable
all right
the same thing is happening
you're picturing in your head
a kind of a
lateral movement through the sagittal
plane
wherein you are moving the person's line
of gravity outside their base of support
and so by default
unknowingly you're traversing the mat
like crazy okay
and again martially
that is low probability if my technique
requires this much space it's going to
require this much time and that's an
abundance of time in which someone can
counter and things like that okay
so what do i mean uh you're doing your
technique and we're going to move all
this way
you can't have that understanding as
you're playing with these sources but
you want to not do that anymore you want
to understand once you understand these
sources you want to just use them that
that's what governs the technique not my
foot patterns
which are based upon some imagery which
may
not be
what you were actually doing okay
so
uh when he enters this technique is done
that's what i'm looking for here
[Music]
that's the same technique
much quicker much shorter
not here
it's much done
done right away so you can boom hit him
and keep moving past him if you wanted
to okay
so
see if we can reduce it to at least
want to tell me
shoot from halfway
okay
let's talk about the pin
you're going to see a different
perspective
leads to an entirely different technique
but you have to look closely because you
guys have been staring at that technique
for decades now and some of you are
still doing the mistakes that are
overtly taught
block clash it's not a strike from luke
it's a strike from you you don't have to
read the body it's actually jodon's ski
they're just hanging out there you push
and pull you do inferior engines like
fulcrum and lever you attack the arm
detect the center all that is wrong
but it's a different technique
it's not the art it's not marshall
okay
you do the pin different too
no i'm just here
it was one ikey adhesion from the first
contact if you remember okay i'm not
pulling nor pushing but he can't get on
off of me there's no gap here do you
understand so i'm doing the same thing
here at the end
i am not
going to hurt him
and then he taps out
why
that's called pain compliance
pain compliance is as marginally
ineffective as fulcrum and lever
does not work who's it work on
it works on voices
it works for non-angry people
that's probably not who's attacking you
so you don't get in the habit or the
assumption that you can hurt people
into quitting
you want control instead
when i'm here what is the control the
control is the adhesion
okay
i take the adhesion and i'm going to
transfer it internally
to
caulk you
because they're sourced from the same
thing
so
as i go
he can't lift up
but i'm not really
so that's what he's going to do
he's going to check if he can lift up
if he starts to move you can move
however you want right i i'm keeping
that adhesion like you're going to get
out of it get your ass out of it okay no
so you don't sit here and go unconscious
you have the same goal he goes and you
follow that in
you follow it in and you keep it under
your center and now you can do your
different things okay
so don't zone out
don't go internal don't shut your eyes
off
you have to keep the same mechanics in
place
such that
if something were to happen
you can respond to it that's point
number one
we go
you're here
alive but heavy
and
with cochlear power
as i'm not pretending that i'm gonna
hurt people
i'm not gonna pretend that i'm pinning
him
because you're not pinning him
he can roll over the top
so
he goes
he's gonna tweak my wrist
go ahead dude
it's not it's not gonna happen
okay it's never gonna happen i'm not
tapping out because you're getting go
ahead and go you see
it's not gonna happen
i i've learned how to reconcile pain
it's not going to happen then you add to
it the fact that if i move the fulcrum
out of its ideal location
everything gets weaker okay
and i could continue to do ikea
if this is the point of contention i
just roll around the point of contention
i'm out
do not
rely on paying compliance
and do not see these as pins
they are a continuation
of the internal skills
got it and transfers
from mikey
to the other side of the internal yin
yang to caulk you but in order to do
that
you have to pay attention that your
awareness stays up and out and alive too
many times you go
into la la land
and the uke goes into la la land got it
okay
let's try
koku and ikey you want an understanding
of them right
and
you don't realize that
your questions
on them are dichotomous
okay and the lesson is introduced
in terms of a dichotomy
but the dichotomy is false it is it is a
narrative it is a it is a poem that's to
convey a feeling in you you see not not
just a feeling of emotion but a feeling
of body mind a particular body mind you
get it and this is why
i do not
venture into
i'll just do tai chi
and then you'll understand
these internal aspects because they're
lost from aikido so cross-train in tai
chi i do not recommend that because
two reasons
one
even in tai chi there are
more people who never get it than do get
it okay
and two
your ultimate aim
is a
reconciliation of the dichotomy the
disappearance of all paradox okay so if
that if i have to do that to over
complicate what i'm doing with an
abundance or an infinite amount of
correspondences
just further and further and further
down the dichotomy rabbit hole i do not
find that you are served by that okay
so
if you
what you ultimately have while i might
talk about a ikea and a call cube
remember it's the yin-yang model so the
yin and the yang are born from the dao
they come from the same thing there's
one thing you see they're not two things
that are totally separate from each
other uh they have the same source and
even in the diagram there's always a
little that's in the other one okay so
there's no such thing as pure idea or
poor
all right you're kind of using this very
simple
just like the data chain there's yin and
yang and then what did they poet say and
from there they 10 000 myriad things
arose ten thousand is the chinese uh
pre-modern number for infinity
everything else comes from this
combination which is ultimately from one
source okay so there's no need to go
into all the different gin there's no
need to go into pong there's just no
need for that if you if you understand
what you're doing you would eventually
have to get rid of those things anyways
okay so for example let's do we'll just
say uh administrative now so his strike
is coming up right
and um
i am
having this this energy his inertia is
going that way and i use that energy to
create the friction that goes around me
do you see that
that is
ikey it's a communion between my hand
and his hand do you see and that energy
is going around me you got it but if you
if you
um
dissected that movement
do you get what i'm saying i'm gonna i'm
not gonna look anymore at the solid
curve and the communion okay the
communion itself is it has within it an
eye key and you can see it i'm not sorry
a coq as you slice the radius up into
its little micro vectors okay so uh for
example
uh let's move him out of the way
and he's going to check a vector by
pushing into it do you see you get it
and he's going he's pushing and
is that ikey this is called q do you see
so the q is in the i key and that is
different for example what you guys
might be doing
is you're doing an external
so it's coming and you're just kind of
yielding and getting it out of the way
you see
so he's going and you're going here
do you see
oh you're just moving out of the way
okay so i'm going to do that lazy
movement and he's going to cut a vector
across that radius so
i here i was going to move it that way
you see okay now he's going to push on
that vector you see it over here and
it's like no no no it's going to
compromise itself do you get it do you
understand okay so within the iq there's
here and if i'm touching him within the
call q there's an i key okay so we're
down to the pin which is where your
question came up
is the transition from the i key
a transition to weight well no because
this is weight this is weight and that's
not what i did and nor is it true that i
didn't have a heaviness in the on the
elbow control throughout the entire time
in that last version because there was
no coq in the ikea that's why there's no
sense of positional integrity got it
which he would experience as weight as
mass as forced you do you get it like i
can't push on that damn thing and i keep
going around it nonetheless okay so it's
not so much and again this is just a
poem too
it's not so much
that
i stopped the i key but
a singular vector has come up do you get
it so
all he's looking for is he's cutting the
ikey radius with the linear vector and
he's just like he did in that last
demonstration right so he's pushing up
and he should feel that i can't push in
on that okay it's not that i'm pinning
his elbow down because i'm not
interested in pinning because this is
not how you pin somebody in a fight okay
i'm just checking myself internally so
he's trying to push up
and i have the same thing okay but as
you saw
as he started to move in the in the
other demonstration
it has the eye key
to it do you see it's not that
i'm sitting here and he pulls it out and
i'm like
got it so this is how to understand it
okay
when you do keemon kihon is not gu kimon
is not play
right
you can do ki hon
you can do kimon like that
as nage
which means i'm i'm in his center i make
sure i'm in his center okay
but that's not key one
if i'm if i'm the nage and i make sure
i'm in his center
regardless if he's in my center
that's not keyhon okay
kihon is i getting his center from a
young perspective
and he gets in my center from a yin
perspective and it leads to an entirely
different looking enchantment okay
but everything is the same so i will
ground vector right
um i will have i can call q as i go
i do have the additional element there
because there is a
um
a kind of um multiple attacker aspect to
uke
that i actively address
he passively address it meaning he's
doing the technique with
the consciousness of multiple attackers
i am doing the technique with the
presence of multiple attackers an
understanding attacker as
two different
uh energy sources
one is him
and the second one is the mat
okay
so as i go into the technique i have to
not only reconcile his energy yin and
yang non-contestation i can't cook you
but i have to do the same to the mat do
you understand so i don't fall to the
mat in some near last way and that has
to be represented okay so as i go into
this technique i'm in his center as much
as he's in mine and he wasn't totally in
my center and you saw the energy leak
out okay so
there is as i felt that technique you're
not in enough i i don't know if you did
or not but it felt like your energy was
out here instead of in here we'll watch
the video to see what happens so you and
there you go now he's in me
oh third step velocity
third step
round
this is different
pick aside once and for all
different
into his body
staying in my mind
you guys see that
question
comments
the transition
from standing to being
not necessarily completely prone on the
map but getting down to them that seems
so soft
and
round
how
what is the
mindset there
i think um
like i said
it's another
energy and i don't push on that energy
do you got it but
i can't
have a weakness
on the on any vector
of the rotation
do you understand
so when we talk about a curve
and what i'm talking about now
is the radius and all these various
points
are like spokes of a wheel
they will not collapse
do you get it
the energy
that keeps
the integrity of the radius
the curve is dependent upon
the integrity
of the linear
energy that creates the possibility of
the curve okay so the radii cannot be
these soft gooey things
unable to take
pressure or force
right that you're going to negate
by trying to say i'm going to go around
it i'm going to go around it you see
um
so when you're coming down
onto the mat
by doing my technique
i'm not going to go boom
you see
that is a strong radius but no curve
nor am i going to go
curve
because it's actually not that smooth a
wheel
you see you can hear it
okay
so
i am in him now so i'll show you you see
i mean him as much as he's in me
so as we go here right uh i'm in one
foot
do you see no different than
when he was pushing
now it's not one foot
we come here
and go ahead get your base got your base
okay and i'm on one foot
so
he tries to push
push
it's the ground vector
do you see well i'm in him as much as
he's in me
then
he's going
to do the ik adhesion around his person
and all i do
is blend
with that energy
blending
means harmonizing yin and yang
but harmonizing yin and yang
means that uke has a my
there's a particular
space time
that i have to do which means i gotta
move
from one point to the other
where the other
is appropriate
and at a rate
that is appropriate do you got it and
that's all he's doing is knocking i'm
doing the same thing as you can okay
well as i said though
there's two things i gotta pay attention
to which is him
and eventually the match
so
when i touch the mat
instead of
boom here
it starts to yield
into it
no different than
when i let him as uk
turn me around i could have you could
keep going do you see you could have
kept going but we're not working that
we're working now you
are going to do
aikido from the inside esuke so he
initiates
he's giving me that energy and i
reconcile that energy i don't go against
it and i don't look for a new opening in
his energy
okay
usually what happens
is why we crash with the mac
aside from theatrics and the
choreographed uk
is
the same reason why you
clash with noggin
right you are afraid you're afraid you
feel you enter into an antagonistic
relationship with them
and as a result awareness goes down your
mind becomes better
so well the same thing happens to the
map if you pay attention before your
lack of harmonization with the mat
you will see the same things
fettered mind unawareness
fear
they're they're there too okay what you
want to do as you get is take advantage
of the fact that in in essence there's
two
energy sources that have to be addressed
with the art not just one that is why
uke is by far
the more cultivating role between nage
and uke okay it's not because i don't
know some weird crazy thing that people
talk about
you're doing more
at more intense levels it is in other
words a more stressful environment and
so it can produce the most adaptation
okay
okay so the
question was on the dichotomy on
dichotomy
and um
the challenge of living life like that
um
remember in our school
the dichotomy is part of what we call
the ego trek part tonight it is it is in
essence the normal or the common or the
popular functioning of the human mind
okay
it simultaneously sets up the ego
identity the sense of self the sense
that yourself who you are you see and uh
has it functioned
as
egocentrically as an interpretive model
for the world okay so it has that one
component there's three components
um
and it's the second the um
the second component which is
it simultaneously gives rise to
dichotomy to dichotomous thought
dichotomous living
right
um which in turn
uh you can have them be quiet
um
you which in turn starts a
life
where it is motivated by
um
avoidance and attraction you see
it comes to us through the to the
simultaneously arising what we call the
three diseases fear pride and ignorance
so if you look at um
most of aikido
that today that's what you see so why do
you block the arm why do you stop the
arm why do you take away the conflict
because you cannot reconcile it do you
see because you have dichotomous so
artificially
taking away
the dichotomy such as ukid does not
actually attack with shomuchi i am
throwing a strike and they block it or
actually ukia doesn't really strike at
all they kind of just stick their arm
out there this is an artificial removal
of the dichotomy
the reason you have to do that is
because you cannot reconcile the
dichotomy because the ego tripartite has
udc but it is every bit as much a
functioning of the ego tripartite as it
is the nage who stops uke who blocks uk
who tries to control the the falcon
lever at the elbow and wrists it is all
dichotomy all abiding and dichotomy
[Music]
what
traditional east asian culture did
is
identify the problem man
us human beings we seem to
ourselves over
by just letting this particular mind of
ours just do what it does
and through that you had the verbs
of philosophies technologies
of self religions traditions that were
trying to
help us transcend
that mind aspect okay
your art aikido is born from those
efforts
this is why it's not aikido if you block
the arm if you stop the uke if you get
rid of artificially all conflict that
that is not ikea
okay
well
where does it
come from like why
why
because it's where the advantage rests
to abide in the ego tripartite
is to
lose to suffer to
endure pain
at the heart of
reconciling the ego tripartite and with
it
solving
for dichotomy
is the quest for wisdom advantage
um the cessation of suffering
do you understand so in in who well what
kind of person seeks that
it's really somebody who's
like i would say he has a kind of uber
ego
like i'm i'm tired of pain i am
so tired of suffering i am tired of
losing like really
really i am and then they stop
so traditionally um and in the moto kyo
this is called spiritual audacity
you see so you can't be
um
a warrior without that kind of like
i'm tired of
of sometimes waiting sometimes losing
you see and if i conflict sometimes i'll
win sometimes i lose if i don't conflict
then i can't lose
you see so who is it is a person that is
really truly truly tired of losing
okay and we call that spiritual audacity
why why do we call it audacity and not
just pride
right because it's abiding in wisdom i'm
going to let go of my ignorance and i'm
going to abide in wisdom why is that
wisdom because
it's the sensation of suffering
it's the it's the generation of
advantage that's why we're calling it
wisdom it's the choosing of one way of
living the world over another way of
living the world okay so if you come to
your aikido
and you're going to block and
fulcrum lever and force and young young
conflicts or or artificially negating
all conflict for you right
um
from the warrior point of view you're
the loser you're a loser
okay you need to dig deeper
and go i want to stop losing
i want to stop
suffering
i want to abide in wisdom i want to find
the way and walk the way
now
again
it's very popular to say
that anyone could walk the way but this
is not historically accurate
the way is narrow the path is narrow
the gate is hidden the gate is small you
will see that all the time but if you
pay attention to your lives
and you're living dichotomously
most of the time you have the effects of
the dichotomy it generates some anxiety
it generates some
reversal of fortune let's say for
example
um
but you eat it up
it's never that great
you see and it's it's even less straight
in terms of negative impact in your life
when you're in the developed west
what really happens to you
and but
because you don't have spiritual
audacity you don't raise the problem you
just endure the negative consequences
it's the same thing when you do your
light training
you see you have your light kihon for
example
and
you're trying to learn the form
administratively in a controlled
environment like today and some of you
just could not
stop
fulfilling and leveraging the elbow you
just could not stop
you weren't ever going to do it
but what is the penalty for not doing it
correctly in kihon was the city none
there's really none
my teacher is so kind he doesn't kick me
out
he lets me stay here and keep doing this
even though i'm not really doing it
he never puts before my face the
hypocrisy and the wasted time that i'm
doing he just lets me keep coming
all i gotta endure is these little snips
those little raisin voice that's about
it
what are you missing this spiritual
audacity where that is not good enough
for you
the worst you have here is when we go
into play or we go into g iwasa and
basically
you can't do anything so really what do
you have how dire is that oh you have to
suffer about an hour
of not being able to do anything
but you're gonna go by your starbucks
and you're gonna watch your movies and
listen to your music you get over it
so it does it's fine
it's fine that's the problem
why is it fine i don't have the
spiritual audacity enough to walk the
narrow path to walk through the hidden
gate
to be no that is not fine
you talk you talk for example about
it's so hard to watch the play videos
because i i so bad i can't do anything
well
let's work on the skill sets that made
you bad
let's work on
this conflict resolution harmonizing yin
and yang and the kihon was a setting
but what did you do the very stuff that
made you bad
lucy
because you can't really change it
externally
it has to be an internal thing it has to
be a true rejection inside of you i will
no longer participate
in this dichotomous
worldview
i will no longer do it i will stop i
will stop
only when you do that
only when you stop
can you start this new way
if you look at the technique how it was
explained today it began with you have
to stop doing these things
and until you
do
then you can try this thing okay so i
would like for you to understand
the need for this spiritual audacity
you have to have it
you have to reach that point in you
where you will not settle for that
lesser you you will stop
you will not wait for rock bottom you
will not wait for these dire
consequences where you have no choice
they will not come
you stop
so you can start